heute vor einem monat wie gesagt hat
putin die ukraine überfallen seither
wird europa ein krieg gekämpft in europa
wie es ihn seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
nicht mehr gab
21 februar
2022 eine rede mit dramatischen folgen
russlands machthaber wladimir putin
spricht in einer fernsehansprache ans
russische volk der ukraine sein
existenzrecht ab das nachbarland habe
nie eine echte staatlichkeit besessen
behauptet putin und geht noch weiter er
unterschreibt einen anlass über die
anerkennung der ostukrainischen gebiet
donezk und lugansk als unabhängige
staaten die separatisten feiern
westliche politiker reagieren zunächst
mit empörung
für all das gibt es keine rechtfertigung
das ist putins krieg
nur wenige stunden später seien ein
marschbefehl in die ost ukraine
putins panzer rollen in gewaltigen
kolonnen durch donetsk angeblich um dort
den frieden zu sichern
24 februar 2022 explosionen und
gefechten in der ferne des main platzes
in kiel am frühen morgen ordnet putin
den militäreinsatz an zerstörung und
trümmer nach angriffen in der ost
ukraine ein gemaltes z wird zum symbol
für putins vernichtungsfeldzug
ja wir gehen mal ganz kurz über weil wir
sind
gebiet unterwegs und wir sehen wie ein
panzer abgeladen wird unmittelbar also
anderthalb kilometer vor der grenze zu
russland in dem gesamten gebiet auf der
gesamten länge die wieder abfahren
ukraine ist präsident wladimir selensky
ruft das kriegsrecht
sie verteilen bereits waffen und werden
sie zur verteidigung unseres landes an
alle verteilt die unsere souveränität
verteidigen wollen und können die
zukunft der ukraine hängt von jedem
bürger ab in den folgenden tagen
verstärkt die russische armee die
angriffe auch großstädte wie kiew mario
pohl und jacky liegen jetzt unter
schweren beschuss durch artillerie und
kanonen feuer
immer durch jetzt hier
ganz eng stickig aber auch schon warm
und es wird auch nach
zustellung auch nachts bewacht werden
müssen
wer kann der flieht richtung westen
ukrainische väter und brüder bleiben
zurück um zu kämpfen
[Musik]
präsident lenski und die klitschko
brüder werden in den medien zu
symbolfiguren für den widerstand in
zahlreichen ländern der eu werden
auffangzentren für die flüchtlinge
errichtet derweil debattieren eu und
nato über verschärfte sanktionen und den
ausschluss russlands aus dem swift
zahlungssystem
28 februar
2022 see lenski reicht eine formelle
bitte um die eu aufnahme seines landes
ein
erster märz 2022 ein 60 kilometer langer
konvoi russischer panzer rollt auf die
ukrainische hauptstadt kiew zu laut
ukrainischen angaben sind auch
belarussische truppen in die ukraine
engagiert
vierter märz 2022
russische streitkräfte greifen das
größte kernkraftwerk europas in japan
auch die atomruine tschernobyl wird
besetzt sie lenski bittet die nato um
errichtung einer flugverbotszone über
der ukraine die bitte wird abgelehnt in
den folgenden tagen mehren sich auch in
russland die kriegs proteste der kreml
reagiert mit unzähligen festnahmen
laut un-flüchtlingshilfswerk
sind rund 1,5 millionen ukraine auf der
flucht in jackie verstecken sich
unzählige in den tunneln des u bahn
systems
elfter märz 2022 gerhard schröder reist
überraschend zu gesprächen nach moskau
der altkanzler war wegen seiner nähe zu
putin zunehmend unter kritik geraten
der riesige panzer konvoi richtung kiew
setzt sich wieder in bewegung und
formiert sich neu ein mögliches
anzeichen für den erwarteten groß ein
die ukraine berichtet von der
bombardierung einer geburtsklinik in
mario pohl auch sogenannte flucht
korridore werden immer wieder
angegriffen
dreizehnter märz 2022
heftige gefechte in irgend einem vorort
von kiew vor den augen von bild reporter
paul ronzheimer wird ein us-journalist
angeschossen
es hat
[Musik]
ja welcher weise sind weit überlegen
auch betroffen das von diesem zeitpunkt
noch nicht sagen
journalist juan arango wird erst später
erfahren dass ein kollege im dauerfeuer
sein leben verloren
vierzehnter märz 2022
die russische journalistin marina osmani
käufer wird durch ihren mutigen protest
im putin tv weltberühmt
21 märz 2022
der russische vormarsch auf die
ukrainische hauptstadt stockt trotzdem
schreckensbilder aus klier großen
display die mir putin hat ein komplettes
einkaufszentrum ein angrenzendes
hochhaus und umstehende gebäude in
schutt und asche legen lassen
einen platz in dem völligen verwüstung
mit denen die einfach mal ein bisschen
durch auch die perspektive zu zeigen und
wenn wir hier oben gehen halt das hier
wurde getroffen
man kann sich vorstellen
welche grafik welche hoch
dieser einschlag hier gestern abend
gehabt hatte
bereits einen monat dauert putins
blutiger krieg in der ukraine an laut
den vereinten nationen sind mehr als
zehn millionen menschen auf der flucht
alle friedensverhandlungen sind bisher
gescheitert
[Musik]